yes but how does it taste
no way
no way no way hey oh my gosh
this metal can exist in all three states
as a liquid
a vapor
and a solid
and
this toxic substance might be lurking
inside you already
so
what would happen if you swallowed
liquid mercury
could too much mercury alter your brain
chemistry
or would it cleanse your system
and
what foods contain the highest amount of
mercury
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you swallowed liquid mercury
in
1804 american explorers lewis and clark
set off to map 12
900 kilometers of land bought from the
french government
and if you wanted to retrace their route
you could use a metal detector instead
of a map
since these two guys ate nothing but
dried meat and whiskey
they supplemented their diets with a
laxative laced with mercury chloride
this pill known as calamel contained a
high dose of mercury and gave this duo
extreme diarrhea
which they called thunderglass
hundreds of years later archaeologists
still find high amounts of mercury in
the soil where their campsites used to
be
marketed as a cure for everything people
thought this popular drug treated
illnesses from syphilis to constipation
mercury i'm your genitals great
you could say it was cleaning out their
systems thoroughly
but did this wonder drug do more harm
than good there are three different
types of mercury called elemental
organic and inorganic
you're probably most familiar with
elemental mercury
that's what you find in thermometers
electrical switches and even dental
fillings
depending on where you live
you might have already had a small dose
with your dinner
microorganisms living on the ocean floor
absorb and break down inorganic mercury
compounds floating in the sea
and when larger fish like mackerel
swordfish or tuna eat these creatures
they contain trace amounts of the toxic
metal
yeah binging out at the sushi bar could
give you a slight case of mercury
poisoning
but if you chugged this liquid metal
like a shot
what would happen to your organs
well in its liquid form mercury is
insoluble meaning it can't break down
further
as this metal passes through your body
only 0.1 of it would remain in your
system
the rest would flush right out
and on its way through you it would kill
bacteria and
violently clean out your intestines
but if this substance remained in your
bloodstream
the toxic effects would begin to destroy
your body
if you kept ingesting liquid mercury it
could build up in your appendix
over time the bacteria in your body
would convert this metal into organic
mercury compounds
and then the real toxic effects would
kick in
once the liquid crosses the blood brain
barrier it could end up inside your
brain causing severe neurological issues
you might suffer from anxiety depression
irritability tremors and numbness
with your muscles weakening and your
lack of coordination your mobility would
be limited
things would get worse when this metal
starts damaging your dna
this would lead to chronic conditions
like als parkinson's disease or even
alzheimer's disease
and excess mercury could impact the
hardest working muscle in your body
your heart
ingesting too much liquid mercury could
cause your heart to grow and the tissue
to thicken
your blood flow would slow and your
cardiovascular system could be in danger
of shutting down
this metal could even impair your kidney
functions and lead to renal cancer
now while liquid mercury could tear you
apart physically and mentally
it still
wouldn't be as dangerous as if you
breathed it in
liquid mercury vaporizes at room
temperature
while consuming this metal can damage
your body over time
inhaling mercury can lead to instant
damage
these tiny invisible atoms have no scent
and they break down in fats and oils
once inside your lungs mercury can
poison your brain
causing sleep disorders and even
paralysis
and unlike water vapor this form of
mercury can linger for days or even
weeks
killing you slowly without you even
knowing
swallowing liquid mercury may not seem
harmful since most of it exits your body
but inhaling the vapor from the buildup
of this toxin could create damage that
lasts a lifetime
so
hold off breaking open that thermometer
now maybe you're still in the mood to
drink some metal anyway
okay what if you swallowed gallium
well get ready to rinse and spit because
that's a story
for another
what if